Hôm qua 1 người thằng chiến năm 2018, tại phương lào kai, tình lào kai, sể ra vụ tên an giá thông phíanh bệ trái từ vong thử tâm.
Thông tin bà đầu, khoảng 12.5 mũ mối phu cùng ngày, ông Thờ, sinh năm 2018, chú phương lào kai, được khiến sẽ mấy, chờ thơ châu hát, sinh năm 2018, đi chở.
Tại đây, ông Thờ dựng sẽ mấy, dù đi mua hàng.
Hí chở ra, bấm đề những sẻ không ngủ mấy, ông Thờ dự chân chống xe để đặc cần khở động.
Đúng nước đó, châu hát đang ngủ chức sẽ bất ngờ vàn tay gà, khiến trước xe lào đi khoảng 15 mũ mấy, và đâm mạnh vào câi, khiến chau hát đủ vong tại chốt,
sau khi xe ra sự việc, công an phương lào kai đã có mặt, phong toả hiện chử và sức miền, làm só hình nhân vụ tên an.
Hình này, tình trạm người đu khiến phương tự xe mùa tốt, xe mấy định để trẻ em mỗi phiếu trước và tự lên, xuống xe mấy đằng giết ra khá phủ biến.
Thật chi có người vụ trẻ xe vụ giữ trẻ ở chức bằng một tay, tìm ở nguy cơ mất an toàn ra thông rất tà.
Ngoài ra, trẻ có thể vẫn tay gà làm xe dị truyền mất kiểm soát.
Cô vừa đó, vì chi sâu thế là vì chi vui hiểm nhất, chỉ cần phành gấp là lực quan tính đẩy trẻ về phiếu trước,
đau hoặc nục trẻ có thể được vào thế lại hoặc trẻ bị văn ra ra.
Các chuyên gia phuyên cáo, khi cho trẻ thăm ra ra thông trình xe gắn mấy, người lớn cần lại xe với tốt đủ đủ địch vừa phải.
Cho trẻ người phiếu sau trong bị mũ bà hiểm cho trẻ từ ba tụi, mang đai trách trình lối với người lại cho những trẻ nhỏ hơn.
Đặc biệt, với trẻ nhỏ một đến hai tụi, ăn toàn nhất là để bán vụ giữ hành người lớn.
Không để trẻ đứng trên xe với bất cứu lý rơi nào.